(announcer)
Amy was just a regular
ordinary girl
in the kingdom of Agribar.
♪ I am a rancid
peasant girl... ♪
(announcer)
Until one day, her most
impossible dreams came true.
(fanfare)
Amy, I'm Willenby,
your royal attaché.
It's time
you knew the truth.
You're not a disgusting,
filthy commoner at all.
You're a princess!
A princess?
Me?!
Oh!
(announcer)
And now her life is going
to change.
I'm a real princess.
♪ I could get used
to this ♪
♪ I deserve this castle
And now it's time
to greet your prince.
My prince?
But of course, every princess
must marry a dashing prince.
Would you like
to meet him?
Fuck yeah, Willenby!
(announcer)
Watch as Amy leaves
her humdrum life behind
and learns the ways of royalty.
Presenting Her Royal Highness,
Princess Amy!
♪♪
(record scratching effect)
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's that dude?
Most certainly.
Your marriage will
legalize the alliance
between our kingdoms.
Yeah, but like I thought,
'cause I'm the princess,
I could, you know,
like pick whoever I want.
(chuckles)
Oh, heavens no.
We must maintain the purity
of the royal bloodline.
Prince Gilligan here is
actually your first cousin.
Yeah, but like
that doesn't seem cool.
Guess what, I'm not into you
either, bitch.
(announcer)
Behold the enchanting romance.
Hey, thank you
for swinging by.
Turns out I'm not really
comfortable
sleeping with a close relative.
And also,
I just turned 14.
According to your
lunar cycle,
now is the optimal time
to conceive.
You're tracking my periods?
Of course.
Incubating a prince is
literally your only role.
But won't the baby
be all like...
Like jacked up?
As sure is my name
is Willenby.
But Willenby!
Now!
(announcer)
Sure, not everything about being
a princess is a piece of cake.
Princess Amy,
for the crime of producing
only female offspring,
you are hereby
sentenced to death.
(crying)
Stop the execution!
Oh, thank God!
I knew the prince would
change his mind.
No, he was assassinated
by his own guards.
But either way, you're free.
(laughing)
Thank you!
(whispering)
Apologies,
Your Highness.
The commoners have revolted
and are demanding
your stupid head.
Kill her!
Oh, come on!
I just wanted to be a princess!